i've uh
[Music]
just tested negative
for cover 19 after isolating for five
days
[Applause]
president biden out of covet isolation
and taking a bit of a victory lap but he
still has some major problems waiting
for him on the horizon biden's
presidency has been battered by bad news
on pretty much every key issue today the
president pivoting back to the one thing
americans still trust him on and that is
fighting the virus biden touting his
administration's response to the
pandemic while taking a shot at guess
who donald trump
you should consider wearing a mask when
you're in a crowded indoor public place
unfortunately this covet is still with
us as it has been for two and a half
years
but our fight against covet is making a
huge difference when my predecessor got
covered he had to get helicoptered to
walter reed medical center he was
severely ill thankfully he recovered
when i got coveted i worked from
upstairs to the white house and the
office is upstairs and for the that
five-day period
the difference is vaccinations of course
and while the president looks relieved
after testing negative his political
problems they are getting worse a new
cnn poll finds 75 percent of democratic
voters want someone else to run in 2024.
and this one quite a shocker pete buttig
is beating joe biden among democrats in
a new hampshire poll because it's never
too early to pull uh new hampshire uh
jesse want to start with the kovid
president's now negative
he needs to drop the tough guy act he's
fallen more times than trump got coveted
he broke his foot playing with his dog
dana
trump was in the hospital for three days
then he gets out of the hospital signs
the abraham accords nominates the
supreme court justice and dances the
ymca until midnight
what is biden talking
mr
about
day weekend should go to the next
nationals game and try to throw out the
first pitch does anybody think he can
throw it better than fauci i highly
doubt it
the mainstream media doesn't even
realize how big of a flip-flop he's done
on kovid19 he campaigned on crushing the
virus
lock it down like china and now he's
saying everyone's gonna get it you gotta
learn to live with it who does that
sound like he it sounds like trump it
sounds like he's for hurt immunity
but i think he kind of liked being
quarantined he looked comfortable in the
basement remember that's how he won the
presidency dana from the basement that's
where they only come in a few hours at a
time he's not surrounded by a lot of
staff confusing them with details he has
his meals he has his sleep he has his
big teleprompter yeah
he has his dog he doesn't have to see
kamala that much it was good and then
i'm thinking wait a second yesterday was
like a flashback to the campaign you had
donald trump giving a speech you had the
department of justice threatening to
indict donald trump you had joe alone in
a room reading off of a teleprompter
while the media lied about everything
he's doing
i honestly think he hopes he probably
gets long coveted because that's a good
strategy for him if he wants to win
again
i wasn't able to look at the news
yesterday but now that you just
described it that way it really was like
being in a time warp what do you make of
everything well i don't i'm trying to
figure out what's in a worse condition
joe or his own party i mean one moment
he's benign and the next moment he's
shouting invective at curtains this guy
shouldn't be talking to china unless
it's the dinnerware
i mean and think of the poor
interpreters they'll stroke out and not
like hunter i haven't seen a guy this
loss since the donner party but his
party is worse they're propping him up
like those photo stand-ins at the
boardwalk and there's no longer a
question if he's running the country it
is who you're looking at this part this
is why i don't like i think it's almost
a mistake
to focus on joe
because i think what's behind joe is
worse the party is in bad shape what's
it stand for it doesn't stand for
victims it stands for criminals doesn't
stand for parents it stands for
activists doesn't stand for women it
stands for woke it's not about children
it's about the teachers union they're
they're they're in such bad shape
they're going after the weakest
republican candidates right yeah in
races and propping them up so that they
can hope that they could beat them later
that's how little confidence that they
have in their own abilities you know
it's a perfect example of left versus
right the left you know the left can't
build things it can only tear things
down whether it's family or the police
or the supreme court or in this case
other candidates because they don't have
any confidence in their own when was the
last time the dems solved the problem
that wasn't political border crime
inflation fentanyl education biden is
the least of their problems you know
well kellyanne conway was on the show
earlier today talking about this poll
let's do do you have that sound bite
control room thank you could you play
kellyanne for us thank you oh bayen's
net favorability is plus 19 among
democrats and independents in new
hampshire
first primary state so if he starts
taking on water within his own party and
is going to face not just headwinds and
poles now but an actual primary
challenge or two within his own party
that spells trouble
it does what's interesting kennedy that
we weren't able to get to but we will
now is that in that poll in new
hampshire of the top demo five democrats
kamala harris was not in the top five no
she she came in at number six and pete
buddha judge who has not been a success
uh in terms of his secretary ship he's
the least awful of all of them so he's
done a bad job he's been completely
elitist he's been m.i.a he has no real
solutions other than to tell poor people
to spend seventy thousand dollars on an
electric vehicle that they can't afford
and somehow uh gas won't be a problem
for them but going into debt for it is
absolutely fine and somehow he is
beating the president and uh i asked
bret baer this the other night when do
we reach critical mass and you know
there have to be people in his inner
circle and you've been there you know
it's like what do they what does the
exit look like hopefully it's better
than how we left afghanistan but it's
got to be you know it's like the the
exit point i think is the most difficult
thing for him when does he announce that
he's not running again is it before the
midterms that's an awful idea is it
after the midterms are you going to
create this scramble with mediocre
californians like kamala harris and
gavin newsom trying to elbow a lame
president out of the way
corey bush is a congresswoman from
missouri uh st louis area gerald i want
you to listen to her because they're
gonna you're probably going to see a lot
more of this kind of thing given the
numbers that we're talking about
do you want to see joe biden run for a
second term she's got to go yeah i you
know that's an easy question that's not
going to take long do you want to see
joe i don't want to answer that question
because we have not that's not yet i
don't want to answer that question
yeah she didn't want to answer it in
geraldo well i think that a lot of
democrats are fearful that people are
you know putting the old age
curse on joe biden thinking that he's uh
you know senile and uh incapable of
holding high office but i see things a
little different as you might expect
than
most of y'all i i believe that today was
a pretty good day for joe biden aside
from the fact that he came out looking
vigorous and i detest people who compare
well my disease to your disease and i'm
i got better and you didn't get better
yeah i think that's absolutely low brow
and
i'm ashamed for him but he had a great
day in the sense that jerome powell the
federal uh
reserve chairman gave him a big wet kiss
as you know dana today
he he said we are not in recession he
said that the labor market is strong
consumer demand is strong
although there will be another raise in
the in the interest rate uh in the
offing
the stock market went nuts on the good
news uh and it seems as if we will
escape uh the worst uh
you know damages of a recession and
that'll be a good thing and just in
terms of polling uh the the poll i saw
that compared generic republicans to
generic democrats you know whoever they
might be was a lot closer than some of
these polls that indicate a republican
route of the democrats especially in the
senate which we will maybe get to a
little bit later hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else